it's definitely a new mission it's a big
emotional entertaining story Ethan Hunt
in this movie finds himself in a much
more personal journey we wrapped and
this is the best mission yet
it's the tougher mission then you always
feel with this one Tom's resort of
doubled down and has done a Spectre
risking his life literally for movie
what the hell is he doing find it best
not some hooker
people talk about the action but what
they're responding to is their
investment of the characters need to
walk away it's to take you places you've
never been is to show you things that
you've never seen and it's to put you in
that experience right there with him
there cannot be peace without first a
great suffering the greater the
suffering the greater the peace then
you've always fear is coming it's coming
blood will be on your word I prayed to
go that it wasn't true
Solomon Lane escaped in Paris now the
world is at risk this is the CIA's
mission you use a scalpel I prefer a
hammer
this is a bad idea
Goodwin honestly he's not just some
observer he's an assassin
I trust anybody outside in this room
you go ro he's been authorized to hunt
you down and kill you
that's the job
no hard feelings
[Music]
what are you waiting for
I'm jumping out a window sorry good luck
when the clock stops Ethan and rooms
everyone I ever cared about
you don't understand what you're
involved in you need to walk away
[Music]
maybe we need
[Music]
accept it either you've lost this one
with Stannis time
what's done is done what we say it's
done shota oh my god
you
you